e
good morning
everyone
welcome to Jael car let's see the um
seing of
alternates here
Jackie and so um representative grassy
you should sit in for representative
Schmidt and that to
Pet's oh well that's fine in this all
right well there's a senator or two you
could fill in all right we do have a
quorum
so the minutes of the previous
meeting move to adopt as written and
presented any comments Corrections
minutes okay those in favor I I
oppos Madame chair yes I wanted to note
U that our transcriptionist is not here
today our reporter uh so it would be
important to for everyone to uh State
their motions clearly and so we know who
did it and I would also ask for the
audience if you come up to the table
whether or not you testify please fill
card that that way we won't have to
name yes good morning representative
Schmidt uh representative grassy you're
in for Senator Whitley
then okay um does anyone have have
agenda okay in that case Madam chair I
move to consent agender as presented
second second by representative Lynn any
discussion those in favor I I
agenda uh so the first item on the
regular agenda is 2023 97 from the real
estate appraiser board uh this
particular proposal does have a number
of issues um the board has been
communicating with our office about
addressing these issues but
unfortunately we've not been able to
resolve all of them um the first being
that there are some sections of this
proposal that have been expired since
February of
2023 um so the committee may have
questions of whether the board has been
enforcing the rules uh in violation of
a22 there's also an unclear comment on
page one of the rule text um the rule
cites to the fee in the federal statute
but the federal statute says that the
required fee being no more than $40 it
does not specify that it is $40 so that
is a little unclear of whether or not
the board is actually charging $40 or
something less than
that also on page one the rule states
that an application will not be accepted
if it's not accompanied by the payment
of the application fee but it's unclear
whether the board is referring to just
the application fee in the PLC rule or
if that also incl includes that
federally required registration
fee ALS on page one there's another
301.8c as
written
um again on page one and again on page
15 there's an unclear because of the way
the rule is written we've been seeing
this a lot lately where it's written as
an indirect requirement meaning that
when you read it it's as though the
application has to provide information
and not the applicant has to provide
information so that has to be Rewritten
to clearly State it's the applicant's
responsibility to provide that
information uh also on page one there's
an unclear uh because there's a
discrepancy between the rule text and
the form that was submitted the form has
required re Ms that are not in the rule
text um on page three and once again on
page 15 uh there's an unclear because
there's a form that's titled experience
log um
but the requirements on that form are
not in the rule text so once again we
have a discrepancy there on page four
there's another unclear which also
appears on page five once again just not
being clear as written the rule text
uses the word information but really it
should be referring to the
application on page four uh this one
might need a legislative fix so there's
a legislative intent Authority unclear
comment because the board is requiring
appraisal management companies to
stipulate and agree that um whether it's
a New Hampshire Court or New Hampshire
agency service may be made on the
executive director of
oplc but the statute itself says that
the service of process may be made on
the secretary of
state so there seems to be a discrepancy
on that as the statute seems pretty
clear but logistically wise it sounds as
though having it served on the executive
director may be the better option so
that would need a legislative fix if if
that's going to continue moving forward
um I have uh quite a few more comments
that I can continue going through or I
think might be U this may be enough for
us to deal with it one time
okay um yeah so so at this point because
of the number of issues um I would just
recommend the committee consider a
preliminary objection at this point so
that the board can address it in a
preliminary objection response and um
like I said the expiration in this
legislative intent comment um would be
something that needs to be addressed
outside of that what's it you want to
move immediately to
that let's from hear from the agency on
the on the the fee question and the
legislative intents
question at least good morning Tina
Kelly office of professional lure and
certification I'm the rules coordinator
and on the fees we're simply what what I
found out was we it is in oplc fee
structure already so we're simply going
to point there for
that and it is probably $40 exactly I
believe that's what it is that's okay
and on the second one the legislative
attent intent I talked to um plc's
Council and it does make more sense to
have it um have it delivered to the
executive director dor rather than the
Secretary of State's office because the
Secretary of State's office is just
going to send it to us and um it's on a
list for um future
legislative um correction okay and about
rules that I
um don't have the answer to that yet
because I was going to address
everything at once these are all things
that we can fix and we can we need to do
more research on um
on that but I can bring it back if if
you were to do a preliminary objection I
could bring it back and that
information I just have one question yes
so again it's about the legislative
intent language as long as the law says
Secretary of State shouldn't the rules
say Secretary of State even though you
might it makes more sense to go to the
executive director but my understanding
from the conversation is the the
language in the exact law says Secretary
of
State Madam chair members of the
committee Lindsay Courtney executive
director oplc I would agree with that
cerling I think the challenge is the
real estate appraisers board used to be
administratively attached to the
Secretary of State so I think this falls
in the bucket of the cleanup language I
think if you if you get behind the plain
language which there's a question of
whether we could I think the intent is
to have the executive director or the
executive off official be the
responsible party for service of process
which used to be the secretary State and
is now the office um I can't recall
whether it's it's slated in that cleanup
language that we've been working on this
session and we can certainly um look
into that um when we come back but I
think that is kind of how we got here
which is which is they used to be
administratively attached to the
secretary more concerned about the fact
that someone May challenge improper
service because the law says where it's
supposed to go and it wasn't done that
way if we put it in the rule and then we
might lose something because we did
something directly
I think that we will make a note of that
and have them respond to the objection
response and we and if the statute is
not slated for immediate cleanup and I
know there's a bunch of them we've got
them in my committee we will change
expect the rule to be changed back to
secretary of state would that agree that
makes sense yes okay representa L you
know I just have a question I the I
mean with regard to the Secretary of
State I'm I'm just curious is there I
wonder if it might make sense to leave
it as Secretary of State just because do
we know you know like what other where
where you have other situations of an
out of state licy um for other agencies
or whatever do you do we know whether
that says the Secretary of State or not
and number one and number two would it
make sense to just have for everybody
that's designating somebody to be their
agent their out of state
just have one person the Secretary of
State be that person thank you
representative Lyn I think that's a
fantastic question and one that we've
been grappling with because as you know
if you have an um an entity a
corporation already registered with the
Secretary of State obviously um there
are ways uh to to affect service of
process by registering your business
with a secretary of state that said
there are a number of boards in our
technical professions that do have the
statutory language that require um in
particular businesses that are
registered or licensed by the office to
also designate the executive director um
as the person to receive for service of
process I don't know from a policy
standpoint whether that makes sense for
the reasons you mention it may make
sense for an individual license but
certainly not sure if it makes sense
from from an entity who's already
registered to do business with the
secretary of state and there's already
that um duplicative process so that's
something we can certainly um consider
and put into the board's
response thank you other
questions all right um we have we
covered all the
points uh the remaining comments that I
have are pretty much all unclear
comments whether it's discrepancies
between the rule text in the forms or
unclear as written or unclear citations
which all could be easily addressed in a
preliminary objection response okay does
someone wish to make make a preliminary
objection second okay move by
representative Schmidt seconded by
Senator
discussion all right those in favor I I
opposed all right thank you we will
expect a response at your at the
appropriate
time and specifically what you've been
doing with the expire
rules
right natural
scientists hey um so uh this is for soil
300 they contain the certification
requirements and the rules set up
application requirements and other
requirements for the certification of
soil and Wetland scientist the board has
filed an amended conditional approval um
which is online you should be able to
pull that up um and I'll be referring to
that for the few issues that remain um a
couple of minor issues is that on page
19 of the uh PDF there the there's a web
link um one of the last uh ones in the
appendex doesn't work and that is easily
fixable today um it can be addressed
orally then on the bottom of the first
page you'll see an informational note
just informing the committee that this
board still has some fee Authority in
its statute but um since there's a lot
of cleanup going on this session might
already be aware of that finally there's
an issue um around the collection of
fees during the time period of the rules
expiration in violation of 541a 22's
prohibition on the enforcement of an
expired rule for any purpose and um
you'll you'll see that um on page I
believe it's a little further down uh
soil
31.03 it had the application fees and
like I said these rules expired in March
um 11th 2019 uh the rules now site to
the new fees that are in the PLC
10002s and uh those are effective as of
August 1st of last year so there's this
gap of unenforceability of the
application fees between those two dates
um the committee has encountered the
situation before with some of the other
boards in recent years and has at times
requested reports and on the number of
um impacted lies and whether or not
refunds have been made um that sort of
thing um as an example of you know doing
that as part of the conditional approval
um but that's up to the committee's
discretion um Ria medley is here today
she is general counsel for the boards
and um I thought she was going to be
speaking I don't see her now but Lindsay
Courtney is also here as well but um
those are the only issues that remain
okay thank you madam chair members of
the committee Lindy Courtney executive
director oplc I'm going to address the
fee issue and then I'll defer to
attorney medley to address any other
issues with respect to the board's rules
so um and I think my statements probably
apply to the next uh uh rules package uh
with respect to Engineers so upon
learning of potential issues and
enforcing expired fee rules I did um I
did look into the matter to determine
root cause it appears that there were
errors in reading the source notes um
and so that there was it it was not
clear immediately apparent that there
were expired fee rules which resulted in
um us continuing to assess fees at lure
and um initial lure and renewal we have
since um instituted uh remedies to
address this issue um which basically
stem from a lack of internal controls
which I think the committee is aware of
that we've been working on since 2019 at
least I've been working on since 2019 um
so a couple of things that we've done is
first PLC 10002s we established those
back in August once the office did
receive or it was clear that the office
had statutory authority to to adopt
rules regarding fees so I think that
moving forward um we should see that
that with respect to fees those issues
have been solved but as to the internal
controls issues regarding expiration of
rules what we've also done is we have a
policy and procedure now um setting for
the specific time frame in which uh
rules need to be um reviewed uh notified
the relevant parties need to be notified
we have a monthly rul making committee
that we review um potential expiring
rules we notify the boards we review
rulem committee requests um for
additional Ru making support and then
separately we've Pur just some software
that will essentially take the human out
of the analysis in terms of when rules
expire we should go live on that next
month um and so I think that going
forward we won't see hopefully um we
won't see any issues with respects to
expired rules uh at least as it relates
to fees and you know the board could
choose to allow a rule to expire
purposely so in terms of refunds I think
the committee is probably aware that
um historically we have issued refunds
in the past if we have um improperly
assess a fee without based on a rule
that was expired I've gone back and I've
taken a look we've definitely done
refunds on Pharmacy we've done refunds
most recently when we did the emergency
rule for coas and Engineers but I don't
think we've ever gone back into a prior
fiscal year and certainly never gone
back into a
penum and I think that
that we need we need to do the right
thing and speaking with doj I'm not sure
that taking money from today's licenses
and refunding it to lenses from 2019
2020 who received the benefit of the
bargain is necessarily the right thing
to do um so their advice is to you know
to the extent that we need to do refunds
we could do refunds from July 1 of this
fiscal year to August one when we didn't
have rules in place this F school year
um but to not go back into a prior by
any
own happy to take any
questions representa yes and I guess I
have a because this has come up with me
um in previous uh discussions when we've
collected money for something let's say
a license but somebody gets the license
and yes the rule has expired but then if
we give back the the money do they do we
not retrieve back the license because it
is a so I think that director Courtney
has a point and if somebody gets that
service even though the rule has
expired I can understand the difficulty
in having the rule expire and not
carrying out the rule and therefore if
we do that then that benefit should be
removed as well that's I think that in
all fairness that's what people pay the
license or the application fee
for and of of course the a license
granted in 2019 would have expired in
2021 so just want to reiterate that we
take this issue very seriously I was
dreading coming here to talk to you
today as much as I love appearing before
legislative committees because this
should never happen ever um and I think
we've done what we need to do to
Institute internal controls but we're
still cleaning up um we're still
cleaning up issues that have long that
time Senator I I just have one question
on page 14 where you have that section
two at the top of the page that actually
says $200 fee but then it also refers to
the fee schedule I'm a little just
nervous that they might get out of sync
and whether it makes sense to strike the
$200 and just say upon payment of fee as
described in the fee schedule and Le
strike the $200 so we don't have an
issue where potentially we get two rules
out of
sync
whether that would be an acceptable edit
so page 14 on a Revis conditional
approval uh
two yes I completely agree with that we
should not we should be referring to the
PLC 10002s because that's how we'll get
into issues moving forward we can make
that
change anyone
else
well we already
um this is already a revised conditional
approval request final approval with the
requested chair It's actually an amended
conditional approval um but yes they can
make these changes orally they can agree
to these today and um like I said at the
outset that web link on page 19 doesn't
work and so that can be part of the
conditional approval today okay so
Senator uh langing moves conditional
approval of the amended conditional
approval request with those two addition
extra changes is that correct okay is
there a second
be director Courtney you you said you
have a new software package to keep
track of your rules is that in sync with
the new software package the
administrative rules department is
working on and and hoping to uh
generally provide that data so um it it
certainly it's not something we've
talked about interfacing it currently
our software is already used by the
Department of Education at my
understanding is it basically captures
information that's on the j court
website basically trolls that
information and puts it into the system
um which we use for tracking and
internal reporting and it also contains
templates that are the templates um that
are contained in the draft manual to
make sure that we limit um any errors in
drafting but I'm certainly happy to talk
to attorney moral about it you know to
make sure that we're we're not thank you
that would that would help but we don't
need more incompatible software systems
I agreed our our updates are actually
being all done in house with our own it
people so we're not uh Contracting
software out but eventually it will have
those those
capabilities all right thank you any
other we have a motion for a conditional
approval is that any further discussion
I think we the C we've had is good okay
those in favor I
opposed all right thank you very
much
okay so the next one uh 2023 167
engineering 300 um these rules set up
application and other requirements for
the licensing of Engineers um the board
has filed um late filed an amended
conditional approval request and the
committee will need to vote to accept
that late filed item since there wasn't
a waiver with that um we could do that
now or we can do that towards the end um
let's let's vote on whether to accept it
so we know what we're talking talking
about so I move that we accept the late
filed conditional approval request
second discussion those in favor I I
opposed we will deal with that there are
um just a few issues that remain with
the proposal and I'll just take the
minor ones first um on page one of the
amended conditional approval packet
there's an informational note um again
that this board still has some fee
Authority and it stat
but that's probably going to be fixed
during the session's cleanup next on
page eight there's a comment um that was
made the last time the rules went
through and that was back in
2013 and um that's that there might be
some need to clarify in the statute that
the third-party testing company develops
the exam rather than having that Duty be
on the board um it kind kind of comes
down to an issue of how to interpret
that that statute's language but like
said this issue was raised before and
the rules were approved despite the
concern um the final issue is is I'd
like to comment on that of course the
professional engineer testing is
standardized Nationwide and we certainly
don't want our board creating its own
test so I and I'm pretty sure that would
have been the uh intent of the
legislature because it's been that way
at least in at least for 50 years so so
I I think we can be fairly confident the
legislative intent is to use the
exam director morl um historically this
has been an issue where statutes were
fairly old regarding any given board it
often required them to create an exam
over time though uh National exams came
about everybody they're standardized
everybody wanted to use them I know a
number of agencies have over the years
uh used corrective legislation uh to do
that but this one I think is a closer
call and I understand your point
too so
um fine we'll add it to the list of
things that could be cleaned
up okayy um the final issue to discuss
is around um the collection of fees
during the time period of the rules
expiration just like the last proposal
if you look at page 13 of the amended
conditional approval packet you'll see a
um and that rule was effective last
August so there's that Gap again between
um January 1st of 2020 and then August
1st of 2023 in which there were no fee
rules on the next page of that packet on
page 14 you'll see a copy of a standing
order that the board issued citing the
expired rules at the time the board that
issu at the time the board issued the
standing order only those two paragraphs
were effective and that was the fee for
certification as a traine and the fee
for um examinations but the standing
order is really about uh bounce checks
um so it's kind of been a roundabout way
I guess you could say enforcing um this
the rules it makes it clear that um that
you know bouncing a check or not paying
for it is a um a disciplinary violation
so U presumably the board was collecting
fees on the expired rule but um just
like you heard on the last proposal um
there have been a lot of um things
implemented to try to prevent this from
happening again but um these were the
proposal thank you again Lindsay
Courtney executive director oplc so my
comments with respect to the fees are
the same with respect to uh soil
scientists I don't believe we've the
board has ever disciplined anybody on a
returned check that's not an issue we
have with the board of Engineers there
are other boards where that's an issue
but um I I don't think that's an issue
with them and I don't think they've ever
discipline what about all the other fees
that are listed there including the a
licensure as a professional
engineer so again I think yet those
certainly were collected um going back
to 2020 my comments are essentially the
same it was an error in reading the
source notes I think at Point um years
ago the rules were valid only for 8
years and some were and then they we
switched to 10 years and certain
portions of the rule were on the 10-year
track and so it wasn't clear um it
wasn't immediately parent to somebody
who's who's not um used to wrting Source
expired any other comments questions
represented or L well again I'm looking
at the 3024 a list of all those fees and
license fees is that is that expired and
not being implemented because it's in
PLC one2 whatever it
is on page 13 a list of all those fees
are now going to is that going in the
rule I'm trying to understand what those
and we're not it doesn't look like it is
that section essentially being deleted
with a reference to uh is that that's
correct trying to
understand
right
appr Senor line moves to approve is
there a
second yes by representative Schmidt any
further
concerns seeing n the representative
Schmid so it it does seem that you are
working out uh some kind of a some kind
of a process here but uh it it seems a
little bit U kind of like oral R making
almost uh which we don't like uh so I'm
wondering is there some alternative to
just kind of like making do
uh would be better clearer and so forth
so I think there are really two options
here I think their fees were improperly
collected which we acknowledge the
question is whether or not we should be
essentially refunding those fees and or
asking for the licenses back for the
work that they've they've done um I
don't think that's the best
solution um and again this obviously
should not happen but I I think moving
forward we need to have a solution in
place which we do but I'm not sure that
we can
really completely rectify the issue in
the
sorry uh I'm more concerned with the you
know putting out a standing order than
the fact that the fees were
collected carrying on but um putting out
a standing order saying we've got the
authority to assess
fees and um
and essentially saying proceed against
someone who who puts out a uh a bad
check yeah I think we asked all of our
boards to do a standing order and we
gave them the templated language because
particularly with certain boards there
were issues many issues with return
checks and as you may know when there's
a return check the fee that the state
incurs the fee on that um again I don't
think and I can confirm but I don't
think Engineers were ever discipl with
respect to this issue and I think uh
this goes back to it wasn't immediately
imper to the board and to the person
assisting them with the standing order
that the rules were actually expired at
at the time um that the standing order
was
issued I see thank you well I'm I'm more
concerned about rectifying the situation
we can't go back and undo the past
obviously and we're kind of uh you know
Rolling Along on flat tires but uh is
there a better procedure um or or
something that is at least better for
the F for ongoing I'm not so concerned
about undoing the pa okay I think that
the solution really was ensuring that
oplc has the authority to set fees so
that we're not going into 50s something
different rule sets to pull out the fees
in multiple different locations so we've
we've you've accomplished that we've
accomplished that we have some fees in
place and we are statutorily required to
do an assessment and a review
periodically we're undertaking that now
we likely will be proposing some
additional fee adjustments which will
result in additional filing which will
result in an additional 10 years and so
I don't see this issue uh happening
again because all of the fees have been
Consolidated in the 102s okay as long as
we're proceeding on an orderly basis
from here on in more comfortable with
questions all right those in favor
I
oppos all right thank you very much and
we're looking forward to that report
right safety okay so um 174 uh
registration hearings so you'll see that
um that there's a legislative intent
comment on this one around um the last
section um let me see here on the final
proposal that would be page three or
actually page seven of the FP packet
however that comment is actually
resolved because this was something that
I missed that that rule has been
extended by 541
A14 and uh it's kind of funny because
I've caught this a lot lately on other
proposals but completely missed this one
so those rules have been extended
because they were filed prior to their
expiration back in August so um I have
no other issues with this
proposal
excellent any
questions motion move to approve second
second by Senator Enis move by rep
Senator L any
discussion those in favor I
opposed all right thank you uh the next
two are not not ready and we'd like to
postpone them to the April meeting so
moved Madame chair uh before you vote on
that 184 will'll need a waiver for jail
car because our April meeting isn't
until the 19th and our deadline was the
15th so we'll also just need a vote on
that I'll add the waiver in my motion
yes we will request to postpone the two
184 all
right already been seconded I believe
okay all right discussion those in favor
I opposed right we will see you next
accountancy so this one actually just
needs an oral conditional approval
because the issues are that it states
Board of septic system evaluators
instead of board of county in um AC
20.01 um and the other issue was that it
mentions uh petitions for waiver of rule
which is the very next section so that
could be deleted but those are the only
two issues and if the board is willing
to take a oral conditional approval we
that it looks as though the this rule
essentially is
repealing vast quantities of of rule is
that correct yes it repeals all the AC
rule 200 rules and um sites to the PLC
rules it's um like many of the boards
are consolidating to to site to a PLC
all right I see your
point we have the conditionally approved
according discussion anything important
to add nothing at this time all
right and
um just questions comments those in
favor
much Madam chair yes um I missed who the
second was on
okay oh sorry and we missed postponing
the lure and disciplinary
sections correct um this next one uh
2023 276 needs to be postponed and no
waiver is needed for it move the
postpone and Grant waiver no waiver you
said no waiver was needed all right so
move the postpone
second okay seconded by by
representative
ly all right those in favor I opposed
um the only issue is that the rules
State a fee that is not delineated in
PLC 10002 and there doesn't appear to be
roeming at this point um to add that Fe
to 10002 so it's it's a little bit of a
difficult situation because
the the board the Board needs to site
to be in PLC 1000002 but it's not in
10002 and that's the OPC that needs to
fix that um so it's kind of like a
situation where this rule isn't really
where it needs to be fixed is this if I
is this the the comment on page three uh
it's on page seven seven okay because on
page three it specifically says that if
there's nothing in the in PLC a00 and
two no
feet I think is a nice general
it's well same thing there they say if
there's no
fee listed in the other rule we won't
charge it so C2 kind of covers it but if
it's not in there until we add it
there's no fee for this like that's
correct
I'm
okay perfectly okay with that myself all
right any other comments concerns motion
move to approve second moved by Senator
Lang second by represent representative
Lynn any
discussion those in favor
I those oppos i' I'd like to comment
that there's a very very nice
uh statement of responses to comments
that is included in this packet and I'm
else exper revision
to okay so this is the expedited
revision to forums
20242 it's uh Bureau of credentialing
for educator fors and there are actually
20 forms in this um this proposal and
there are a handful that have some
issues uh for example there's a title
that is different on in the worldle text
in the form there are three that uh that
refer to the um school year 20123 2024
which means the the it would need to be
editorial changed every year um and
there's uh a couple that have
requirements uh that are not in the rule
and a certification that is not in the
rule so uh our after discussing with the
agency we' discuss getting a preliminary
objection just because unfortunately in
this this process at the moment we don't
have a CA uh conditional approval
process um so you have to do a
preliminary objection to get those those
revisions done um and so I think that's
what we had talked about before um that
that process is coming in legislation
but it's just not here yet
comments administrative rules
coordinator Department of Ed I'm Susan
Blake administrator for the Bureau of
credentialing Department of
Ed so how do you feel about the uh the
suggested procedure
um so the first um suggestion that was
um put to us was the um on doe boc2 the
application for ler um we'd be happy to
change the rule to reflect the um
recommendation of the name change on the
form on doe sorry sorry I like the
question is I think we all agree we we
know what the issues are I think the
question is are you okay with the
process that we preliminary object to
give you to make the corrections
necessary and then bring it back so we
can approve it yes that's fine so sorry
okay s the line move to preliminary
object that
good move by Senator L second by
representative Schmidt any
discussion all right those in favor I I
much really
rolling
we do not yet have the watercraft safety
rules that's correct um and it's not due
till April 1st so that one's still
rule
okay with the chair's permission uh I
think it would be good to have the
agency go first to
explain U why they're doing the
emergency
role good morning I didn't know I was
the agency good morning I'm Helen Hanks
I'm the commissioner of the Department
of Corrections but I am a member of the
opioid batement commission uh and the
commission at the last meeting asked if
a member could come and join our
stewards from HHS to talk about the
emergency
rule uh the emergency rule is before you
because the commission has really found
after its uh lengthy work uh since
implementation of the trust fund that we
need to make some adjustments as a state
uh to recognize that both locally at the
county level and even at the state level
there are opportunities to be more
Nimble to get the opioid trust fund
dollars out swiftly um to uh Abate the
effect of opioids in our communities and
that's what this rule is attempting uh
to do I can get into some specific
specific details um if the committee has
questions glad to see that you're
intending to enter into into regular rul
making to uh confirm
this any other comments um I am not
prepared to argue that uh they there is
no basis for emergency rule I I think
arguably there is a basis um however the
rule itself and the uh cover sheet for
the Emergency Rule raise a number of
questions
um I can uh I can give those to the
department and I think for the most part
they can be uh addressed during the
regular rulemaking process which will be
necessary okay excellent that that is
where that sort of
uh concern would should be addressed
yeah there were a couple things though
um if you see on the first page of the
emergency rule in 03 F the definition of
eligible entity is being changed and it
seems to be taking out government
agencies but it's my understanding that
the purpose of the uh emergency rule is
to put in a couple of Emer uh a couple
of government agencies
so I wasn't sure why they're changing
the definition of eligible entity and
the other major concern I think is
that um the current process for doing
this is in
10205 um which is not part of the
emergency Rule and that requires getting
an RFP and other steps um I think the
idea with the emergency rule is to do an
abbreviated uh process for these uh uh
two
entities um however that means that
you're going to have two separate
processes in the rule uh which may make
a Clarity issue but perhaps they can
amend
10205 uh or the emergenc the language of
this you give us some information on
that good morning uh Alison radme I'm
the administrator for the rules unit at
the Department of Health and Human
Services um with respect to um the the
comments that attorney moral had just
made um it has after reading this and it
being pointed out um that in the regular
rulemaking uh process uh we will be
changing
fback uh to read how it uh originally uh
States um and I apologize we don't have
uh one 10205 in front of us uh to review
and uh respond to that this time but
again any comments we receive will be
addressed in the regular Ru making
process um which we to begin uh quite
shortly would it be fair to say that the
process
1,205 is intended to be followed for for
grants hold on please
sorry
Madam chair yes I I I no the new
entities would not follow the process in
1025 uh the cabet explains that that uh
would take too long to get this
Implement uh the use of the funds by
these two entities so they're creating
this
exception
see so I think that you when you enter
into regular rul making you should in
fact include that section on the process
to
indicate so that at least it's
rules any other comments
questions okay we don't have to do
anything on emergency rules but uh we
will see what comes out of the regular
rule thank you don't
we don't have to approve I'm sorry
moving I'm moving to the next item we
don't we don't need a me a middle
meeting we don't need no no I think we
will by uh consensus cancel the uh
continued meeting and plan to meet at a
regular scheduled meeting on April
19th
okay that case there's any any other
business
Reed